we are back with another episode of
steampunks the show where we roll
through all the latest releases on Steam
over the last week and let you know
what's worth playing my name is Jessa
McDonald and I'm Edmund trend and
without further ado let's get into it
what was your first game my first game
was called blood-stained curse of the
moon so you may have heard of a game
called blood stain ritual tonight it's
the Kickstarter project from Koji
Igarashi who created the timeless
classic Castlevania Symphony of the
Night and basically helped usher in this
sort of whole new genre of games
so when ritual denied the main game was
in its kicks out of phase and absolutely
smashed its goal it got like 10 times
the asking price and like eventually
raised like 5.5 million dollars and
anyway one of the really really lofty
stretch goals was just a whole nother
game and one that was a revival of the
old-school Nintendo console vania games
rather than
Igarashi the PlayStation Sega Saturn one
so this is blood-stained Coast of the
Moon it's an S style Castlevania game
developed by the Japanese company called
inti creates who started off as former
Capcom employees and sort of have a
history-making really really great 2d
platformer games Khosla moon is 8-bit
feels exactly like ultracar Albania and
that's great I really love this stuff I
really like precise sort of pixel
perfect platforming and this simple no
not just combat in true cost mania style
you have your primary weapon and you can
pick up a variety of sub weapons that
use up mana and you kill a bunch of
dudes it's also a little frustrating
sometimes because it has the old-school
mentality of every time you get hit by
an enemy you get knocked back and
possibly into a pit that's kind of part
of the charm and challenge now the big
features that set this one apart from
actual old-school Castlevania is that it
graciously has things like checkpoints
and it also has branching paths through
levels so you can take different routes
that have different challenges this is a
prequel game to the main blood-stained
project so it uses a lot of the same
characters and once you unlock them
through the story in this game you can
switch between them and use their
different abilities for example you
started as n gets ooh-hoo-hoo nationally
has a sword then you unlock Miriam who's
the protagonist of the main game who has
a whip and the ability to sort of slide
into tight spaces that's his secret
areas and alternate paths and once you
die with a certain character
and actually goes back to their
checkpoint and you get to keep going
with two characters and once you lose
all those guys you actually lose a life
coast of the moon has some really really
nice level and boss design I think it's
pretty great so far it's ten bucks on
Steam and it's also basically on all the
consoles as well and if you back the
Kickstarter at the 30 bucks here you'll
already have a code so play it
[Music]
now Jesse also played a sort of revival
of a classic PlayStation game yes I did
it was my first entry into this pixel
junk franchise but I did play pixel
drive monsters too which if you don't
know anything about it is a strategic
realtime tower defense game where
everything looks like it fell out of a
really adorable kids cartoon so you play
as taking in you're the chief of the
chibis these like adorable little Tiki
dudes and your job is to make sure they
don't get picked off by transforming
trees along the path of attack between
the enemy spawn point and your village
into a variety of weapons so you can go
to what any tree and turn it into a
cannon that attacks ground-based foes
some anti air weaponry or something that
does a little bit of both as you can
expect you have a certain number of
coins you need to spend those coins to
build towers so placement of those
towers is key because they are not
infinite aside from the coins you'll
also occasionally pick up gems which can
be spent on either leveling up your
towers or you can spend them on a
variety of berries that have effects
like freeze and explode so when enemies
come across them it does a really good
job of decimating their forces dancing
next to your towers will also make them
level faster and the early thing you
need to do to do that is just stand
still near them as you get through it
there are more options for towers the
kind of attack capabilities they'll have
and defensive capabilities are added as
you go you can somewhat scan to a
different direction to see a little
further but you can't see the entirety
of the map at the same time which means
you don't necessarily know what enemy is
incoming I really enjoy co-op and it is
fun in this game but it is really
glitchy right now I assume this is
something that's gonna be worked on as
the game has just come out you also
currently seem to have to opt back in
with your co-op partner for every single
stage which can be a pain when you
wanted to sit down and play a bunch of
levels the aesthetic of this game is so
cute the music is really nice and it's
enjoyable to play I think some of these
quality of life fixes which it sound
like existed in the first game if they
were applied I think this would be a
really good experience
[Music]
yeah I used to love playing the original
pixel drunken monsters game on
PlayStation 3 so I'm looking forward to
playing fixed junk monsters too cuz that
game gets really hard but not as hard as
this next one Dark Souls remastered
that's pretty hot it's pretty hard you
probably already know what Dark Souls is
if for some reason you don't it's the
hard core medieval Japanese action RPG
that caused a huge wave in the gaming
world because if it's incredibly
challenging combat and the demands it
asks you as a player like be very
careful and observe new enemy's behavior
and internalize it for the next time you
see them it also started the trend of
you will die a lot and when you die you
lose all your experience points that
you've collected unless you can reach
the place where you died and retrieve
them which still remains a great
mechanic in my mind and also mented the
most wonderful form of multiplayer you
could opt to go online and have the
ability to summon another player to come
help you out with something and Dark
Souls remastered is surprised the
remaster the first game in this series
which came out in 2011 it remains the
best of the three Dark Souls games just
because of it's a wonderful level design
which kind of loops in on itself
beautifully so Namco's telling you that
this remaster boasts 60 frames per
second and 4k resolutions super high
resolution textures and new lighting
design as well as a few small
quality-of-life fixes now the question
probably asking a zappiti player is like
sure that's really great for the
versions on ps4 and Xbox one but what's
the big deal on PC where everything like
sort of scales the original PC release
of Dark Souls it was prepared to die
edition was notoriously horrible it used
games for Windows Live for online play
and DRM which as you probably know was a
terrible terrible service it had a hard
cap of its resolution at 7:20 which is
outrageous at PC and the community mod
had to be made to unlock this resolution
so Dark Souls remastered PC replaces
prepare to die edition and yet it just
works at 4k resolution at of the box but
obviously a lot of owners are myths that
they couldn't just have that
patched yeah there's no one which is
fair you know my impression where yeah
look it's not a very pretty game by
today's standards and the series of
mechanics have become a lot more
applying since then but like I said this
is like still heralded as the best Dark
Souls for a reason so if you know you
loved it or you've been curious
definitely give it a go there are people
complaining about hackers with the pvp
stuff so maybe stay away from that for
the moment on PC das das remastered is
40 bucks and you get a 50% discount on
it if you already earned prepare to die
edition I get that
okay well finally we have a game that we
both played which is a whole other kind
of heart it is yet another survival game
what's a survival games XP see that's PC
called raft your spawn in the middle of
the ocean and you need to gather debris
floating by
make sure you have food and water and
try not to get eaten by sharks so this
game is in early access and it has a
little to no instruction of what you
should do or what you need to do so it
took us a lot of trial and error of
realizing I get off the rock get off the
raft that was the number one learning
you only have one raft and you can't
build another one you can build
extensions to the raft that already
exists you can build all kinds of things
like water purifiers crop beds if you
can get seeds from any of the islands
you go by once you do get the hang of
things it starts to flow more smoothly
and you get into that survival game loop
of like okay let's just keep a keep one
eye on how much my water stores are
going one eye on do we have food that's
coming in you can do things like uncover
blueprints where you can make entirely
new things that aren't actually in the
basic crafting menu at all using the
research table yeah we found stuff like
radio antenna and a receiver which yeah
hints is something more so you can build
like different levels on your raft you
can make it an enormous and and you can
just build chairs and like chill hours
yeah look imagine any other survival
game and building like yourself imagine
you just build that on the water
unfortunately if you want to play co-op
you do need friends who already have it
there's no online matchmaking with
randoms at the moment so hopefully
that's something that will come up
eventually yes sir this le axis version
is basically the raft gameplay and
learning how to survive and build your
raft but they've said that on this same
page that they're planning to include a
lot more sort of quests and ventures
sort of things like sunken ships and
cities or like kind of stuff so yeah
looking forward to seeing what they do
with it
probably be a while before all of that
stuff comes in but there are a lot of
people playing this right now
it's for good reason I didn't like the
hook so this one's 20 bucks and
that's pretty decent I'd say for what it
is it's a really cute and pretty unique
survival game and if you can get a
friend on board all the better
alright we're done for this week for
steampunks that's all the games we have
if you've played any of them and want to
tell us about your experience with them
especially raft let's do let us know on
our Twitter accounts I'm a teddy bear
and I'm at just Macdonald until next
week we'll see you later
you
[Music]